An ongoing crisis and a tragic loss have affected
the "Pawn Stars" family. Rick Harrison
has finally opened up about what happened.
On January 19, 2024, "Pawn Stars" lead Rick
Harrison's son Adam passed away. He was 39 years
old. While initial reports suggested an overdose,
details at the time were scarce. However,
Rick Harrison has confirmed to TMZ that the
cause of death had been a fentanyl overdose.
Harrison told TMZ:
"Yes, I can confirm Adam died from
a fentanyl overdose. The fentanyl
crisis in this country must be taken
more seriously. It seems it is just
flowing over the borders and nothing is
being done about it. We must do better."
As TMZ also notes, the Harrison family
previously released a statement asking
they be given time amongst themselves to
grapple with this devastating news. It said:
"Our family is extremely saddened by the death of
Adam. We ask for privacy as we grieve his loss."
Fans of "Pawn Stars" know that while
Rick Harrison's family is fairly active
in his business — including his sons
Corey and Jake — Adam Harrison did not
appear on the History Channel series.
Before the show began airing in 2009,
Adam was reportedly involved in the family
business. However, according to his brother Corey,
he later branched out and pursued a career as
a plumber, living his life independently and
avoiding the nearly inescapable fame that comes
with appearing on such a hit television series.
While fans and friends of the Harrison family are
certainly respecting their wishes for privacy at
this time, there was still an outpouring
of support on social media regarding Adam
Harrison's tragic passing. When Rick Harrison
posted an Instagram tribute to his late son,
fans responded to the post with well wishes.
Radio host Joe Pags wrote in a comment,
"Sorry to hear about this, Rick. Sending prayers."
Actor Emilio Rivera, known for
his roles in "Flamin' Hot" and
"Mayans M.C.," paid his respects as well, writing,
"Rest in Peace ... My Condolences
to You and the Familia."
Donald Trump Jr., son of former president
Donald Trump, also responded to the post,
simply writing, "I'm so sorry man."
It wasn't just famous figures who
turned up to show their support for
Rick. Fans of the show also offered their
condolences, with one person writing:
"I am so sorry for your loss Rick. Too many of our
children are taken by the disease of addiction."
Corey Harrison, who was just
one year older than his brother,
also took to Instagram to post a tribute with
a picture of the pair when they were younger.
As Rick Harrison noted in his statement to TMZ,
the ongoing fentanyl and opioid addiction crisis
in the United States is nothing short of horrific.
According to the National Institute on Drug Abuse,
death rates from overdoses have been
steadily increasing in recent years.
"We're in a crisis where they don't even
really have an answer. As a result of that,
more and more people are going to die."
Because of that, it's not surprising
that pop culture has tried to unpack
this devastating situation, whether
these projects approach the subject
head-on or create some sort
of allegorical narrative.
Hulu's "Dopesick" tackles the battle
against Purdue Pharma and their marketing
of OxyContin. Netflix's "Painkiller" also
discusses Purdue but directly adapts its
story from Patrick Radden Keefe's New
Yorker article "The Family That Built
an Empire of Pain" and Barry Meier's book,
"Pain Killer: An Empire of Deceit and the
Origin of America's Opioid Epidemic,"
which zeroes in on the Sackler family.
Even in the horror genre, Mike Flanagan
addresses the Sacklers in "The Fall of
the House of Usher," modeling the fictional
Usher family after the Sacklers and showing
just how their corporate greed led to
widespread addiction and tragic death.
It's awful to see yet another promising life cut
short in real life when it comes
to Adam Harrison's sudden passing.